I don't say this you are one of my
favorite actors ever I am so thrilled
that you're on this thank you and and
and I was completely blown away by our
performance in this latest James Bond
movie but I must begin by congratulating
you you got a star yeah on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame was that today yeah
actually today today is the Javier
Bardem day in Hollywood I said that
means that everybody has to walk with a
broken nose it was this a dream of yours
ever as an actor as a young boy do you
think someday I'll get a star
no remotely no something that sounds
kind of surreal for ya it's a great
honor of course yeah would you would you
go and visit this store often I've
always wondered do people go in to visit
their stores well yes I guess one day
when it's a night and there's nobody
there I can otherwise it would be too
weird no not me not me Javier I would be
there in daylight if I had a star
whose face that name I must ask you
first of all you are no stranger as an
actor to trying different hairstyles no
country for old men obviously in this
Bond film you play Silva and you have
this incredible blonde hair do I think
we can show this right here
yeah it really Loa getting so a lot of
use and odds here
did you like having that hairstyle well
look who's talking my goal my goal the
only reason why I keep on playing
characters is just trying to find a
character with on her style with this
hairstyle you're her stuff you're your
Oscar winning actor one of the greatest
actors in the world and your only focus
is to have my hair yeah it's an
obsession for me every time I read a
script I go like where's the herd
where's the you could have gone with
this hair as Silva the Bond villain you
could have done this I try by the video
said that's what people say to me when
they see my hair I think we have a
rendition of what it would have looked
like
[Applause]
is by far the best option yeah okay I am
not reading into this a lot of people
had the same reaction the the opening
scene I'm not giving anything away but
there's an opening scene where you first
meet James Bond I believe one of the
greatest meetings of the Bond villain
and Bond in the history of the franchise
it's a fantastic scene and then it
really does seem like you are coming on
to James Bond in a very sexually
aggressive way and no one sees that
coming in this scene is am i
interpreting that correctly
[Applause]
oh why did you stop
happiest I've been in here you're not
the only one with dreams you know Javier
you got the pole you got it boys